you posted a picture of your hands  clasped together take us inside the room  at that moment what was happening well  he has so many you know there's so many  cords everywhere you know I just wanted  up in his bed and hug him and grab him  and squeeze it but you know you have to  be very careful with everything that's  going on so I grabbed his hand and I I  massaged his hand and I hold his hand  and I'm waiting for the day that he  holds my hand back yeah yeah I mean here  we are Amanda we sit here very much part  of team Nick it's day 90 and you say  despite everything you've been through  and you've been through a lot you are  not defeated you say yes I just feel  like when I'm in that room with him and  then when I come home don't get me wrong  I have my days but I have to stay  determined I have to stay positive I  have to stay strong for my husband he's  still fighting he's in there and he's  fighting and so he can still fight after  90 days I can still fight after 90 days